December 18th 2015 the quarantine zone
in the middle of Manhattan later known
as the dark zone was abandoned by the
government and the Joint Task Force they
left behind weapons equipment thousands
of civilians and the first wave of
division agents although it has assumed
that the majority of the first wave were
killed or went rogue there are a number
that just simply disappeared what we do
know is that some of them managed to
escape the quarantine zone and make
their way to the outside of Manhattan
Island in this series we're going to
follow these agents and speculate on
what happened to them based on the
psychological profiles and the location
of where their watches and other
information was fountain
[Music]
Piper Gibson is a private school in Ivy
League legacy who switched to emergency
medicine after a years residency in the
South Bronx
Piper stays cool under pressure and
treats more gunshot wounds than any
other doctor in the city she is
pioneered treatment techniques that were
later adopted by the army Piper is
fluent in Spanish and French and is
proficient at Krav Maga of what she has
used on multiple occasions in emergency
room confrontations she's repeatedly
refused promotion to more administrative
positions to keep herself engaged in the
ER she is advocated relentlessly by her
patients and will often go beyond the
call of duty to secure resources and get
them the help they need
on occasion Piper exhibits a certain
sense of entitlement possibly due to her
upbringing this will often lead to her
expecting to get what she wants and when
she wants them and when this isn't
achieved she doesn't take the
disappointment well Piper Gibson's watch
an ID was found in the Clinton district
a couple of blocks from the dark zone on
her way from escaping the quarantine
zone she came across an area completely
overrun by the Rika's gang also in the
area was the Joint Task Force but they
were losing the fight from in control of
the situation being an ER medic has
specialized in gunshot wounds
she joined up the JTF to assist in the
treatment of the wounded eventually they
were overrun the writers had a
stronghold set up close by and any
prisoners were taken away to be
statistically tortured in the most
inhumane ways imaginable
Piper's file was found in a courtyard
that became the final resting place for
a number of JTF officers that were left
butchered and hanging from the
surrounding balconies this area is
littered with bottles and cans it's
unlikely that they were killed quickly
there is no sign of Piper Gibson's body
but given the rough his reputation in
regards to their treatment of government
authorities it's safe to say that
Piper's final moments were not pleasant
Jerome Norton is the son of one of the
first responders who died at 9/11 three
years after the tragedy Jerome listed in
the United States Marine corpse here he
found himself in natural marksmen acing
Sniper school and being awarded a Silver
Star for a service in Iran during his
time he was wounded twice in the line of
duty but both times he returned to the
field quickly after military Jerome had
a rough time transitioning into civilian
life shortly after returning to the
United States he had two arrests for
being drunk and disorderly a family
member pulled him aside to turn around
the situation he was digging himself
into Jerome gave up alcohol and got into
a plumber's union apprenticeship where
he's been working on city projects ever
since to the people around him he
clearly misses the camaraderie of
military service and although he claims
not to miss the action most would say
that this isn't the case Jerome has a
strong sense of right and wrong with a
little room for moral complexity he
strongly believes in honor and duty but
may struggle with situational
flexibility Jerome's watch an ID can be
found in the Clinton district a little
over a block away from the quarantine
zone after making his way through Times
Square an area heavily occupied by the
raucous gang he took refuge in a garage
he only made it a short distance from
the position perhaps he was injured and
unable to go any further but being a
battle-hardened ex-marine with a crack
shot it's possible that his fate was led
down a different path ever since Jerome
left the military he's had a bit of a
gap in his existence years in the
surface working hard and playing harder
building relationships that brought him
closer to people than his own family the
pride and excellence associated with the
Marines that is drilled into the hits
daily
isn't something that the general public
is concerned about the expectations and
perfectionism of the ex Marines will be
a lifelong battle that has to be dealt
with but people are creatures of habit
and leaving a life behind suddenly after
years of service could be a challenge
for even the strongest among us aaron
keener would have picked up on his
vulnerability in Jerome's character
given that the first wave of division
agents as a whole felt betrayed by the
government when they were left behind in
the quarantine zone it wouldn't have
been difficult to manipulate this
already vulnerable personality kina
would only have to point out the fact
that they were on
and that they needed to work together
availed to be successful in their
mission the government didn't have the
people's best interests in mind it was
up to them to get the job done
it's possible that Jerome was sent out
to investigate Jordan Amherst apartment
as his watch was only found a block over
it's unknown how this mission went but
given that Pina was always one step
ahead of the division it will be fair to
say that drone was able to gather the
Intel the keener needed to further
progress as plans
you
Gina Esteban has been a priest an
activist a social worker and a nurse she
spent five years in El Salvador and
Nicaragua
working with the poor after a stint with
Doctors Without Borders
Gina opened a clinic in East Harlem and
has been devoting herself to helping the
young the sick and the elderly Gina is
well and truly the mother Teresa every
time she is deeply religious in a
proponent of non-violence but does
believe that self-defense is sometimes
warranted Gina is also a crack shot with
a pistol through her assistance with the
local communities she's earned the
respect of the local street gangs and in
turn they have set it to provide an
informal security detail to watch over
the clinic this has led to allegations
that she was providing the local gangs
with drugs but this is since being
investigated and dismissed
Gina leads through personal magnetism
devotion to the peace into patients this
could be seen as a weakness but she's
fiercely protective of those under her
watch
Gina is two bands watch an ID can be
found in an apartment building in the
garment district not far from the dark
zone Gina barely made it a block from
the dark zone this makes sense as
running from the people in need doesn't
fit in with a profile she may have been
forced from the quarantine zone by
hostiles but likely it plans to return
when she heard of the issues between the
government and the rest of the first
wave she likely shared herself of any
allegiance to the strategic homeland
division to avoid all of the politics
that was distracting them from what
should have been their main priority
protecting the weak Gina went on to do
what she does best and set out to tend
to the Forgotten civilians stuck in the
middle of this tragedy given her
location she was likely to have had some
dealings with a Michael to frame who was
a nurse that was taking advantage of the
current situation and selling medicine
and supplies to the highest bidder it's
also possible when considering our
history that she was working with the
local gangs to help provide the supplies
she needed to help the vulnerable
citizens of New York she may have even
been a part of the ambush that had
Michael kidnapped by the rioters to take
a stolen medicine and force him to tend
to the sick
Michael's later reluctantly rescued by
the second way of division agents
josephus is an experienced cameraman
spending time and emergency in war zones
is covered crime natural disasters
revolution and war while in Iraq he was
kidnapped twice but due to his ability
to keep calm under pressure even under
the most difficult of situations is able
to come out of it unharmed
Joe receive the Louisiana middle of
honor for rescuing a drowning child
while filming stories about Hurricane
Katrina
it's said that Joe can drive any vehicle
imaginable and has probably done so
while out on assignment Joe's an
impulsive individual and will take
chances for the sake of the story he
won't hesitate to put himself at risk
but this isn't to say that it will risk
the life of others only his own Joe
services watch an ID can be found in the
Tenderloin district just outside of the
dark zone it could be assumed that Joe
escaped the dark zone and immediately
headed west towards Camp Hudson
but given Joe's psychological profile
this is unlikely Joe may have still left
the dark zone in order to gather himself
in an area that was less hostile but
given the fact that this was such a
unique situation followed by the
government up and leaving the area
meaning that civilians were left to fend
for themselves alongside a number of
growing hostile factions this was a
story too good to be true and Joe had a
front row seat jodan straight up to non
the government and he certainly didn't
jump straight into bed with Aaron Kino
at least not straight away he set
himself up to tell the story of the
going ons in Manhattan New York
completely unafraid to dive into the
restricted areas and approach
authorities Joe wasn't going to go and
let anything get between him and getting
the story out to the public it's not
completely clear why but Joe decided
that his identity needed to be hidden
this was possibly a result of the first
wave agents starting to turn against the
government and him trying to put some
space between himself in the first wave
rogue agents Joe goes on to tell the
public about the events happening in the
city based on either his first-hand
observations or information from his
sources this information was often
classified or beyond what even the JTF
was aware of Joe surveys was attempting
to be the voice and ears of the city
could he be the identity behind a
character in the division that we've
been listening to on and off for the
last two to three years
the true identity of a
- Rick the lessee your uncle Ricky
these are just my theories and
speculations best of the story missions
encounters until and the psychological
profiles of the agents and question it's
completely possible that they simply
died after contracting the virus or were
outright killed by the hostile factions
or even errant kinas crew I'll be the
first to admit that there are a number
of different possible outcomes what I'm
really trying to achieve is to open up
your mind to the potential and
possibilities that the division story
has to offer and spark discussion within
the community so tell me what do you
think happened to these agents what
theories do you have regarding the
division story as per usual I can't
finish up the video without thanking
some of the many fabulous supporters of
the channel especially Devereaux and
foxy this has been particularly amazing
at this time as the division 1 is coming
to an end and understandably people are
starting to move on to other titles
while they wait for the release of the
division 2 so division content
viewership has dropped dramatically but
these are the people that are ensuring
that I continue to push out these sorts
of videos until the franchise picks up
the game and I'm thankful because I love
this game and I want to continue the
hype towards the sequel for as long as I
can thank you for taking the time to
watch this video if you'd like to jump
into a community full of division geeks
like myself please visit the discord
link in the description thanks again and
see you in the next one Cheers
you
you